rupture stars new Mira Posten is the
story of a mother who is deathly afraid
of spiders
she makes Jeff Daniels and arachnophobia
look like nothing he'll hyperventilate
she'll scream she'll stop moving she'll
have to get other people to take the
spider away from her and when a strange
group of people abduct her and start
doing experiments on her to hopefully
make her rupture as they call it well
the film just gets weirder and weirder
and weirder I don't want to tiptoe
around this I have not seen a movie in a
very long time that started out fairly
promising get so awful as fast as
rupture Wow this film is an absolute
train wreck the best part of this movie
is nume repose
she is a fearless actress I cannot
praise her enough she has given some
absolutely absurd dialogue and thrown
into some hilariously over-the-top
sequences and she gives it 110 percent
she is throwing herself all over the
room in these confinement scenes she's
crawling through dirty ventilation
shafts she's slamming herself all over
the room she is giving this performance
so much emotion she is in a completely
different universe as everyone else
involved with making this movie she is
so so good in this film and everything
else is crumbling around her I have no
idea what they were thinking with this
movie I really can't get into spoilers
but part of me wants to but don't worry
I won't it goes in a very sci-fi heavy
route it starts out as your
stereotypical woman in confinement movie
the polite thing to say would be that
this movie gets very ambitious but it
kind of doesn't it reminded me of a lot
of other films that I had seen before
just played through a more low-budget
route and definitely in the wrong way
Michael Chiklis is also in this film
he's one of the people that abduct her
and this group of people just got so
silly
I could not help but laugh and I was so
sad that I was sitting there laughing
because I saw new Mira Paz and she is
just she is truly owning
every frame that this movie has to offer
she is just so damn good in this film
and everything else just does not get to
her level even close to her level the
story goes in such absurd directions
that I left I mean I laughed quite often
actually and it was disappointing
because I watched the first 20 minutes
of this movie on Amazon video and then I
had to run and do something really quick
as soon as I was done with that I was
actually really excited to get back to
the movie because I was into it for the
first act and then it just turns into a
complete disaster of awful CGI
hilariously bad dialogue and a sci-fi
plot and an ending that felt so so
unsatisfying that I actually audibly
screamed what at the screen when it
ended and that's rare for me I was at
home alone watching it on Amazon but
like rarely ever do I just go like what
when a film ends and this film got that
way for me not only does the ending not
really make sense because two characters
teleport from a living room to in the
middle of a street but it's vastly
unsatisfying this entire film just went
from pretty promising to awful in a span
of about 25 minutes I wouldn't waste my
money on rupture I'm gonna give it a
deed again new Mira Paz is amazing in
this film she is so much better than
everything else in it I was enticed by
it because of her I think she's so
talented but she deserved far better
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
[Music]
Oh